we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p the voicemail
line made possible this month by our
good friends over at ling this the
language learning app that gauges your
skill level finds your weaknesses and
puts that all together with everything
we know about neuroscience and
memorization to personalize the language
learning program for you i've been using
it to improve my french
i love it i encourage you to try it for
free no credit card needed ling viscom /
pakman ling vista with a v.com / pakman
here is a voicemail an inspiring
voicemail related to my segment last
week about Bernie Sanders weaknesses
take a listen hi David my name is Jeremy
I've been listening to you show for a
few weeks and I really like it I was
probably gonna sign up for a membership
anyways but at some point but what
inspired me to do it today was hearing
your segment about how people were
cancelling their memberships because you
did that big thing that was like a
thought experiment on the best arguments
against Bernie Sanders I'm probably
gonna end up winning for Bernie but I
thought that was a good segment I found
just completely ridiculous there's
people who you know are gonna quit the
show because you're entertaining I guess
the best arguments against him and so I
just thought that was ridiculous and
inspired me to sign up for memberships
so keep up the great work I really like
the show thanks bye really appreciate
this really appreciate this yeah last
week there were people who said David
could you please do an argument a video
about the strongest arguments against
Bernie I did it and then a couple people
cancelled membership saying that was a
really bad segment to do you should have
also talked about the reasons to vote
for Bernie Sanders which I do all the
time because I might vote for him and
he's in my top Democratic primary
candidates so thank you really
appreciate someone saying I'm gonna sign
out for a membership because that was a
good segment and now they will get
access to the bonus show which is coming
up next
become a member become a patron to get
instant access